il mio vero nome è fabrizio lavoro il
mio soprannome
nicchi sono un musicista un chitarrista
un dj e
soprattutto uno speaker cioè sono uno
speaker al ted ex di vicenza oggi ma in
genere sono uno speaker alla radio
allora la radio non va molto d'accordo
con con il concetto di pausa però in
realtà oggi sono qui proprio per parlare
dell'importanza della pausa e del potere
della pausa
tutti sappiamo che a volte prendiamo un
po il giro per esempio se stiamo
correndo
facciamo un po fatica a rompere il fiato
però una volta che siamo dentro siamo
caldi continuiamo e facciamo e facciamo
km o magari stiamo facendo un trasloco
no sembra impossibile portare tutte le
nostre cose in un'altra casa però
iniziamo a fare scatoloni dividiamo la
nostra vita il cd libri investiti
facciamo un viaggio facciamo un altro
viaggio cominciamo a vedere che l'altro
a casa prende forma insomma non bisogna
smettere quando si è quando si e caldi
come con un libro no magari le prime
pagine ci risultano un po un po
difficili da leggere poi prendiamo il
giro 10 20 30 80 pagine 100 pagine e
finiamo magari un libro in una sera io
sono qui per parlare del dell'uso della
pausa in maniera in maniera consapevole
no se viviamo la nostra vita proviamo a
immaginare di vivere la nostra vita come
se fosse una canzone e nella musica la
pausa è importantissima importante
almeno tanto quanto le note noi pensiamo
sempre alle note no
tra l'altro anche lino sentiamo una
canzone che assomiglia tantissimo
un'altra canzone e prima o poi qualcuno
dirà la solita frase e va beh le note
sono sette in fondo le note non sono
esattamente sette le sette note sono
quelle dei tasti bianchi del pianoforte
non ne facciamo una scala non so do re
mi fa però insomma tra il do e il re c'è
il dott
isis ho chiamato anche re bemolle e via
dicendo quindi non possiamo essere così
snob nei confronti dei bemolle e dei
diesis di sicuro però tutti sono molto
nobile confronti della pausa facciamo un
esempio prendiamo una canzone di grande
successo tra l'altro bellissima tipo
ello di adele no adesso facciamo una
cattiva imitazione di adel la canzone
inizia c'è un
lasciamo perdere insomma adele e
inimitabile però insomma la canzone non
sarebbe stata la stessa se non ci
fossero state queste pause andiamo nel
immenso il magico mondo del rock and
roll pensiamo a quel capolavoro che è
back in black degli ac dc no inizia con
un con un colpo di charleston c'era un
certo punto una pausa di due quarti
pausa
allora chitarristi si fermano davanti la
batteria continua andare avanti ma mal
con niang e da una parte angustia da una
parte si fermavano pensa un altro super
classico del rock and roll i clash sud
est en scene gol bausan batteria
insomma non sarebbe stata la stessa cosa
se il riff di chitarra avesse continuato
insomma ci voleva quella pausa per
poterli apprezzare poi la mazzata del
rifo la mazzata della della batteria
i nirvana i nirvana tu pensa che orco
ben sta facendo il rid della canzone
batterie basso sono fermi scatta il poco
adesso a teatro non vi fate male è se
dovete dovete pagare feto senza che si
sta ok
ok ok e poi arriva la calma no quindi
insomma questo alternarsi di mazzate di
dolcezza di pausa molto importante
adesso non so se possiamo vivere la
nostra vita come se fosse una canzone
parla di sicuro ci sono delle canzoni
che sono in grado di cambiarti la vita
tutti noi secondo me abbiamo un momento
nella nostra infanzia della nostra
adolescenza quando c'è una canzone che
ci cattura è una volta che ci ha
catturato ci ha catturato per il resto
della vita
io presento il ricordo questo momento
della mia vita in cui scoprono che pete
townsend il chitarrista dave dice
bisogna vivere la nostra vita come
quella volta in cui abbiamo sentito
jumping jack flash dei rolling stones
sicuramente può valere anche per altre
canzoni non a tutti insomma cambiato la
vita jumping jack flash però una fase
importante insomma più vado avanti e più
mi sembra che abbia senso io penso a un
altro momento penso a quel concerto
chiamato live aid del 1985 io ho 14 anni
era una specie di adesso sarebbe il
coachella o grasso brain in inghilterra
cui ci sono i buyers trezzi che salgono
sul palco la gente è pazza sente che sta
per succedere qualcosa c'è questo questo
intro che continua che continua
cresceranno tutti sulle mani si vede
anche un signore con una tunica bianca
che forse e sting dei police
no batterista comincia a fare qualcosa
il chitarrista in assoluta pausa non ha
ancora fatto neanche una nota ma dentro
sta salendo
salgono le rullate arriva una piccola
pausa chitarrista che comincia a fare
qualcosa ma poi si ferma tutto è
scattato
i rischi chitarra più belli della storia
del rock and roll questo il resto della
band è in pausa ma qui tutto lo stadio
inizia a battere le mani come potrebbe
essere adesso al teatro stato
mamma mia ragazzi emozionante ho ancora
i brividi no a pensarci adesso è la
pausa è una cosa importantissima anche
per la vita di una band rock non si
fanno le canzoni si registrano si fanno
i dischi poi si va in tournée poi ci si
ritira per ripetere un giro in giro
simile ecco in radio come vi raccontavo
all'inizio la pausa non è che vada tanto
bene c'è la radio ha un pessimo rapporto
con la pausa quando stai ascoltando la
radio sentire due secondi di silenzio
vuol dire che è successo qualcosa di non
buono insomma c'è stato un problema è
saltato il disco noi siamo un flusso
costante di voce musica pubblicità poi
ritorna della musica poi ritorna a
qualcuno a parlare il silenzio non è non
è contemplato no e a volte però c'è
bisogno di una pausa una delle domande
che ci viene spesso fatta non credo a me
ma come i miei colleghi oa chiunque
faccia radio magari anche presente in
sala
ma voi come fate a essere sempre sempre
allegri no siete sempre presi bene
condividete il vostro entusiasmo non vi
capita di essere poco ispirati la
risposta è si può capitare una giornata
un po storta a volte può capitare magari
un periodo in cui non si riesce più a
condividere quello che si riesce a
condividere abitualmente a me capita un
periodo del genere
qualche anno fa dove sento che forse sto
un po bleffando non quell'entusiasmo che
che in genere è spontaneo non è più
tanto spontaneo forse c'è bisogno di di
fare delle altre esperienze allora
schiaccio pausa scendo da questo treno
in corsa
perché così immagini
un po un po la radio deciso di staccare
insomma mi licenzio
basta insomma se non si può fare vorrà
dire che farò qualcos'altro magari un
giorno ci ritorno è deciso di fare un
giro del mondo
magari lavorando come ho sempre sentito
ho sempre sentito tanti racconti non ho
mollato tutto finito l'università sono
andato a lavorare in australia proviamo
inizio da new york dove dove mi era
capitato di andare a fare qualche
viaggetto alla settimana le due
settimane le tre settimane il mese è
arrivato a new york e mi rendo conto che
non c'è bisogno di girare il resto del
mondo forse tutto il mondo che cerco è
compreso in questa città insomma non
proprio piccolissima
voi direte ma new york è la città che
non dorme mai ma cosa fai fai una pausa
da tutto sto casino della radio e vai
proprio in una città si però è un po il
discorso degli strumenti che sono in
pausa no per esempio new york è un posto
fantastico per per ascoltare no le
storie di persone che arrivano da tutto
il mondo per osservare c'è gente che
arriva dal giappone ci sono gli arabi
sono gli svedesi ci sono gli europei ci
sono gli africani
ogni tanto anche qualche americano è lo
puoi incontrare insomma qualche festa
trovi lavoro magari in un ristorante e
scopri che il padrone del ristorante è
uno che ha delle idee molto simili a
quell'uomo politico di adesso con quella
pettinatura un po molto particolare
insomma diciamo un conservatore insomma
vorrebbe costruire delle frontiere non
far entrare questi neri quest ispanici
questi messicani però nel suo ristorante
lavorano dei messicani che stanno
lavorando lì illegalmente hanno passato
la frontiera a piedi e se non ci fossero
loro diciamo il ristorante collasserebbe
no quindi insomma qualcosa che ti fa
riflettere 6 a un party la sera incontri
delle persone che arriva tutto il mondo
ha certo punto vedi uno che fa o ciao
ragazzi me ne vado o non ci siamo
parlati scusa ma di dove sei ma
dell'iraq che l'iraq ma facciamo due
chiacchiere insomma spiega mi un po del
tuo paese quindi
un grande periodo di assorbimento di
informazioni a un certo punto sento che
comincia a riaffiorare di nuovo il
desiderio di di condividere note è
tornato un certo entusiasmo ritorno
dalle nostre parti e per fortuna insomma
una porta aperta alla radio c'è ancora
vengo a sapere che un cantante che ho
sempre stimato una grande rockstar
secondo me forse lo vedremo le nostre
spalle fra poco il cantante originale
dei van halen david lee roth quelli di
jump è un po che non si fa sentire non
riesco a trovare sue informazioni ha
fatto insomma migliaia di concerti ha
venduto milioni di dischi ma riesco più
a capire che cosa sta facendo cerco su
facebook su twitter su instagram vengo a
sapere dopo che sto facendo il
volontario sulle ambulanze di new york
quando c'è una sparatoria nel bronx o a
brooklyn ma non nelle zone hipster di
brooke e nelle zone dove la vita è
ancora un po dura lui arriva da
volontario osserva da una mano estrarre
pallottole cerca di dare del supporto
psicologico dopo un paio d'anni torna
più in forma che mai ritorna con la sua
band i van halen ritorna a riempire gli
stadi gira tutto il mondo ha il suo
video podcast ha adesso a 60 anni e
tutti i giorni pubblica qualcosa e
condividere il suo entusiasmo insomma
quel tipo di pausa gli è servito quindi
che cosa vorrei dirvi dobbiamo
rivalutare secondo me il concetto di
pausa perché ogni stop è solo un altro
start come diceva una canzone di una
band italiana chiamata casino royale
finisce qualcosa inizia a qualcos'altro
un po come quando vai a fare una vacanza
e nel viaggio di ritorno ti prende un po
di malinconia perché sei andato verso un
posto hai fatto un viaggio quando torni
stai ritornando ma stai andando in fondo
sempre verso qualcosa quindi rivalutiamo
la pausa riconsideriamo la pausa
rispetto per la pausa potere alla pausa
grazie ciao a tutti